the strands in your eyes they color them  one I've been looking forward to this  moment ever since baby Tommy was cut out  of my abdomen cheers everybody  [Music]  it's time now  there are pirates and they took  everybody a message where is the pattern  of the pride  Robert Robert they're calling you so  thanks a lot Carol  here's the plan we're gonna head to the  next Island for help on my count  this weekend hasn't exactly got a plan I  reached chasing he wasn't on your vision  board you're the only thing on my  mission right is that blood  [Music]  foreign  was that brain stuff well you know what  maybe we should let's just step away  [Music]